欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,最后一小节我们来讲一下关于保障力的提升的方法以及它的坑有哪些
这个板块也是非常重要的
首先我们来看一下它的指标具体有哪些,就是这三个指标
那么我们从最简单的最容易实现的去讲解
首先是轨迹上网及时率,也就是你订单成交之后有物流单号了
你要及时的填上去, 一定要保证不留单号, 一定要跟你发货国家地址是一样的
你要保证它的国家是一致的, 否则你这里就会出现异常
异常的话那么你这里占比就会很低
第二个就是买价评价分, 买价评价分的话
通常我们以4.8作为一个临界点, 4.8分作为一个临界点
因为只有4.8分的时候你的产品以及你的店铺才有更多的产品能够进入到
评价的分的这个榜单里面, 只有4.8分才能够满足条件进入这个榜单
获取更多的流量, 同时呢4.8分能够更有吸引力去把客户
转化成寻盘, 因为很多客户他看到你, 如果你评价低于4.7分那么是不是信任度就低
那么他发寻盘的概率是不是就小了, 所以说这个是一个
非常重要的一个
临界值, 一定要按照4.8去评分
那么这个时候我们就要去
让业务邀请一些比较好的客户来进行一个评分
评分最好都是五星, 至少至少你要在四星, 千万不要
低于四星, 那么低四星的话, 那么你整个店铺的话
4.8分就很难达成了
所以一定要
让业务主动的去邀请, 同时给业务制定一些好评的
福利, 或者是给客户
送一些福利, 也就是
业务员可以给一些奖励
客户也可以
得到一些福利, 这样的话你的评分就很快就能够拉升起来了
第二种方法呢
如果你有很多买家账号, 那么你可以去下一些小单
自己去收获, 自己去评价
也是很快拉升你
整个店铺的4.8分
如果你低于这个分数, 那么你就按照这种方法去快速的拉升就可以了
最后一个就是风险健康分, 这个很重要, 但是呢很多人
去忽视了, 因为这里面
有一个
发货率的
数据, 也就是这个发货率的数据, 如果你这个发货率低于80的时候
无论你这些星级有多高
也就是你这些都是五星是吧
或者是四星三星
只要你发货率低于80, 那么你整个店铺就是零星, 所以一定要重视这个发货率, 这个发货率是
基础标准, 它跟你这些
一定有一定的占比分, 但是这个是
核心的一个
门槛基础, 也就是你没达到80%的, 整个店铺就是零星
所以一定要重视, 你看这里有一个
按时发货率的一个
分值, 一个指标, 你可以按照这个去判断就可以了, 如果你店铺里面有很多
逾期被发货, 导致
发货率低于80%的时候, 那么也有
非常快的方法可以提升的, 第一个就是
前期我们要在发货的时候, 起草订单的时候, 你一定要把你的
发货的周期填
长一点时间, 这样的话我们就不容易遗期
第二个就是
你已经遗期的订单, 你去找
对应时间内的物流去填写上去, 也是可以提升你整个
订单的发货率的
第三个就是, 我们自己
通过
自己补单, 然后
把物流单号其实填上去
那么我们这个补单的方法
也可以快速的提升我们的这个发货率的
只需要
三到五天内, 你这个发货率就能提升起来了
所以你
这个发货率
必须在每个月25号
或者是23号前
就知道
这个发货率
一定是达标的, 如果
你在25号
前发现这个发货率没有达到80%
那么你
都是有时间去提升的
也足够
时间去提升
那么这个你就要根据具体的实际情况
去提升就可以了
这个就是关于
关于保障力提升的一些方法
任何的一个指标
都能提升
关键是你要找到
具体指标存在什么样的问题
然后再针对这个指标
采用
对应的方法去提升
就行了
我们把
重点的问题找到
再解决这个问题
那么我们
整个店铺
的
总体的新等级就能够更加稳定
才能够
确保我们每一个月
都能够稳定的
获得力量
好了, 这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再会见